this is a production of Cornell
University
so so I I got a special treat that you
can call bonus content right bonus
content uh for the show if you want to
uh edit this out you you feel free to do
so but since we've got uh Brother Rich
here I I we have to start out with his
insight
uh on on this momentous occasion about
to take place at Cornell University uh
for those of you watching on NewsChannel
10 I'm showing the logo from the 1977
concert with the Grateful Dead that was
held here that is considered by
aficionados to be among their most
finest performances and Rich you talked
about
um how them practicing with little feet
uh in advance it is for a while uh got
them good and tight something they
weren't usually but I guess most people
in attendance didn't notice the
difference so was there just a lot of a
lot of fewer Stone people here at
Cornell or or they were really good I I
well the dead was really good and and
there's an argument among deadheads
whether Cornell is the best show ever or
not but it was certainly through a
period 1977 might be one of the best
years you know it depends on your taste
as in Dead music but that they were
tight and they had a good repertoire and
they they were uh as good as they can
get put it that way and and like you
know it might not just be the Cornell
show all of spring 77 even up into uh uh
a show from from here Englishtown in
September
um uh they they were great and and uh
there's a lot of uh you know you can
listen to the shows the record store day
is this week and they're putting out uh
May 5th 77 from Buffalo okay and that's
a great show too okay all right so
listen Carl I'm just gonna take it from
here uh welcome to the Cornell Turf Show
uh I'm Frank Rossi with my colleague
Carl skimenti and our good friend Rich
Buckley the director of diagnostic
services down there at Rutgers
University and I'll just start it out
for those of you watching not listening
a wonderful uh evening picture from
Johnny Paquette uh down at Indian Hills
on Long Island just a beautiful property
that Johnny takes a lot of pride in and
love when superintendents have good
pictures and Carl you know good BMP in
the morning is a check your irrigation
system and oh this head's sticking on
there and this superintendent said well
you know wonder why it's sticking on you
look close you can see there's a big old
rock in there uh blocking the road or
preventing it from spinning so you know
a reminder to get out there and check
those heads don't just turn them on
assuming they're working get out there
because we're going to talk more about
that now just uh you know what we used
to do back in the kova days is remind
everybody uh you know as we get going
there's other people who rely on us many
times and and also good to take some
time and go see a live show every once
in a while right Rich maybe 175 of them
in in a good year right at least every
two weeks it's necessary all right good
so okay now looking at the weather Carl
here's what I can tell you it's been
warmer than normal you know you didn't
need a HD to find that out it was 20
degrees above normal in the Metro New
York area and more so than that up in
the Rochester area you know you get out
into Western New York even in the
Adirondacks you're talking in that about
20 degrees above normal now for those of
you that use the forecast website now
you might not have noticed this but
we've got this timeline above all of our
Maps now that maybe you haven't seen it
sometimes we have it there for pests a
lot uh here is you know what it was like
you can see last week it was 11 14 and
14 degrees up above normal here in the
Ithaca area right and it's telling me
that the next bunch of days you can tell
are going to get a little bit cooler or
a little bit closer to normal right as
as we look at temperature departure
moving forward so most are about 10 to
21 days ahead of normal when you look at
Growing Degree Days the accumulated heat
uh over the LA from March 15th when we
try to say this is when it's happening
now there might have been some
accumulation at the end of February this
past year but for right now everybody
the ma the data saying the season is
ahead of normal now there's other things
that are signs of that the peak annual
bluegrass seed head flush is now
probably prominent in the metropolitan
New York area and South so you're going
to find out pretty quick how your seed
head program worked this year as the
seed heads start to come on and any
stress particularly drought will enhance
and amplify the seed head uh bursts that
you get as typical in with annual
Bluegrass so most have been dry so we're
setting up a little on the dry side here
quarter inch except Rich did you get a
bunch of rain last week it looks like
some of these areas got three to four
inches you didn't get that I didn't I
didn't see three or four inches I mean
it rained but not like that so yeah that
is some heavy rain in in Northern and
central western New Jersey now in the
last month right you look at the cumin
relative effect to about where a little
bit before was short of where we are now
there's a dry gradient in the west and
the Northwest from Buffalo Rochester the
northern part of New York really on the
Wet Side 150 to 200 percent of normal
and then as you get to the southeast
around towards Long Island the Delmarva
down where you are rich it's been dry
for the last month now things may be
picking up ET is certainly uh picking up
but the drought Monitor and this is the
one from last week we're waiting for the
new one for this week it comes out on
Thursday before all of this comes
together but we're starting to get
measurable dry weather in the Delmarva
into Philly Harrisburg PA Southern
Jersey Hudson Valley Orange County
across Southeastern Connecticut all the
way over to Rhode Island so you know
we're starting to set up to be pretty
dry and it you know it's sort of not
getting a signal one way or the other
how much rain we're going to get we got
a forecast from art this morning in
indicating maybe about an inch an inch
and a half of rain potentially passing
through almost all of it expected on
Sunday this week
dry soils means warmer soils and as we
start our conversation with Rich today
we'll start with thinking okay first off
one of our early signals for pathogen
control and the kinds of pathogens that
we want to talk about today Rich are are
these soil temperatures building right
as the soil temperature builds the
microbial activity in the soil begins to
increase and some of those microbes like
to feed on plant roots now here's some
data from your colleague at NC State Lee
Butler Lee puts out on his website every
year his samples uh stuff when he gets
them right and he looked at his 14-year
average compared to 2022 and his data
indicates on his bent Poe submissions
and he gets them from all over the
country like you do and his bent Poe
submissions last year
his Peak was lower and later than last
year and I brought this up because in
our casual conversation I think this has
been pretty consistent with what your
season was like last year you had fewer
samples uh and they were later now the
conversation that I'm gonna pass it to
Carl to talk about is the summer patch
and the root pathogen conversation uh
moving forward but how about this Rich
would this characterize your diagnostic
sample submissions they were lower and
words was the peak later last year it
well for us we were definitely lower I
was uh down about 30 percent
um from from the year before and we were
in a Range that was close to the to the
level from 30 years ago I mean that's
how that's how few we had and ours we
had a weird pattern
um where it was wet early in and so we
peaked early and then we trailed off as
it dried out in in our area in the
Northeast and and I always think that uh
you know it's easier to add water when
it's droughty than it is to take it away
when it's wet and and we were kind of
wet May June and then we dried out and
it and it was that's how it was
reflected in the sample submission
perfect okay so as we call Venture end
and I pass it to you brother this is a
picture that Todd Lowe uh he used to be
with the USGA in Florida now he's with
end view or I'm gonna get in trouble I
don't one of the companies down there uh
he's still working in Florida this was a
Bermuda grass tea that these sections
were phrase mode
for Springs to plant somewhere else
and the large patch which I think is a
soil-borne pathogen is it rich large
patch it's a rhizoctoney it's you know a
famous or brown patch you know okay but
it's coming out of the soil but it's a
foliar patch yeah I mean it it survives
well in the soil and uh it makes
corrosia and but the diseases of foliar
disease yeah so only in the foliage that
got phrase mode did they see it so
really uh fascinating uh phenomenon and
teaches us how little we know about this
so Carl let me let you put talk about
this wonderful little rant you put
together it's really going to set up
rich for a lively conversation on root
pathogens today go ahead girl yeah so so
this is something I've heard you guys
talk about for a while Frank these root
pathogens and maybe being more of a
concern up here uh as the climate is
sort of changing and I've heard you guys
talk about this idea of you know so War
of Attrition and when we think about
Roots right we've got to sort of build
this massive Roots early in the year
because whether it's root pathogens
whether it's uh heat or drought you know
nematodes or something they're gonna get
uh eaten away over the course of the
summer right so this idea that you have
to build a solid root system early on
and that's going to help you get through
some of these pathogens even if you're
you're good or not so good at
controlling them with the drenches and
stuff like that so I decided to take a
look okay when is sort of the ideal root
growth when it comes to soil
temperatures uh you can get some stuff
from James Beard here in 2001. he's got
a cool little three-pager turf grass
root Basics and he says that the optimum
group growth temperatures for for our
cool season grasses are right around 50
to 65 degrees Fahrenheit Frank you just
showed soil temperatures in the region
the southern parts of our region are
getting right into their low 50s now mid
50s so we're creeping it to that Ideal
Time To Build The Roots right to build
for that war of attrition once we get to
80 degrees ish soil temperatures that's
when uh you know James Beard says Hey
critical root loss that's when we're
going to start to lose from sort of
abiotic stresses then you look at the
disease cycle and say okay when are the
disease is coming on well they start to
in fact at 19 to 20 degrees Celsius
that's made the upper 60s right after
our optimal group growth and they Peak
fungal growth Peaks at 28 degrees see
that's low 80s so right is the the root
growth is slowing the path engines are
coming on so so James Beard had this
little slide here he sort of Drew a
little line of Ideal root growth
activity and then I drew a red line uh
that's sort of the summer patch pathogen
that's when it's coming on and you see
for those watching that's peaking right
when root growth is waning right so this
idea of War of Attrition we got to build
those roots early on right now what can
we do to do that uh you can do you could
do it with nitrogen you got to find that
sort of a nice balance of not too much
not too little you can do it with
perfect but I think from a lot of
superintendents I've talked to build
good root systems it starts with
irrigation right we talk with Rick
Slattery a lot he helped us build this
panel in our sustainable golf handbook
that we just released right QR codes on
the screen there a little stress goes a
long way and we have these little icons
up here that indicate hey do this in the
shoulders of the season right when that
root growth is Optimum right whether
it's in the spring or the fall
intentionally allowing some moisture
stress right let's see where that
wilting point is early in the year
because hey it's the springtime it's not
going to get away from you quick right
even if we get these you plus 10 plus 12
Degree Days Frank takes a long time to
get to that maximum temperature during
the day we don't have all that day
length we've got cooler nighttime temps
to sort of buffer that so explore where
that wilting point is early in the year
let it dry down that's going to help
push your roots deep right so we make
this sort of analogy to athletes where
uh you've got you got to stress the the
turf a little bit to build that
resiliency to build that that root
system and we talk about deepen and
frequent irrigation right so deeper
Cycles wetting the soil down six inches
a little bit past where the roots are
maybe even eight inches there's data on
this from Peter noden uh Jim and food
did this down in Maryland right and for
those who can see there's uh deep and
infrequent uh irrigation how how many uh
basically root surface area there is
compared to light and frequent and in
all these root Zone depths there's more
Roots uh in the deep and infrequent
approach so that's what I think of what
I've heard from superintendents who
build those solid root systems get them
through the year right that's where it
starts to sort of give you some leeway
for for these root pathogens
stress in the turf a little bit let it
dry down and then those deep and
infrequent Cycles are going to help you
build those roots right now uh to get
you through the summer this is brilliant
Carl absolutely brilliant to this
particular chart here when you're
looking at this thing so rich Let's
Start here this is great
um is this when you start to get samples
right because we've talked about this in
the past
um
does a little stress in the summer help
or her uh a little stress in the spring
sorry in the spring does a little stress
in the spring stress or or does it help
or hurt I think it you're gonna it's
clear it's going to help you a little
bit right
um you know prepping for the summer
um you know it
that's if you have good plants and you
have good roots you know I was looking
at a sample yesterday and I'm like this
is summer patch but I shouldn't see any
dead grass here but the root system was
already so troubling that I don't think
this this particular superintendent is
going to have grass by the time it gets
to mid-summer you know and and so so uh
I I don't know how you recover if you're
already in trouble now right so so uh so
so again I think if you have healthy
grass and you can stress it and you know
clearly from the data that's a good
thing but if you don't you're in trouble
so yeah Frank that's a good question too
there's stress there's uh mowing stress
we're not saying hey go and Mo and mo at
100 and roll every day we're saying
stressing from the irrigation
perspective and Rick and Rich was just
saying hey last year when the spring was
wet when we had all that moisture in the
system when it's tough to take it out
okay that's when we start to see samples
but if you get a dry spring it's
interesting you know maybe we get fewer
samples in and because we're sort of
building that deep root system through
uh basically drought stress through
moisture stress not through the hammer
in it getting it down to height low
Heights and rolling right so there's a
distinction there I think that's
important I agree 100 and I and I think
to to me it begs the question that you
know you're going to get feeding uh on
these roots does more Roots help or hurt
right the theory is have a more it's the
war of attrition but The Season's really
long too so let's talk about this Rich
we're getting longer periods of
infection I think Carl's Wright having a
deeper root system is there but we'll
that's not gonna just completely prevent
this so let's start to take this apart a
little bit from a control perspective
would you recommend instead of spraying
fungicides out of the gate on this as
well as you should start using ammonium
sulfate acidifying fertilizers in your
nutrient program is that a good first
line of defense let's assume you got
plants that will grow roots because you
know let's assume you don't have plants
that that stress that Carl's talking
about sets them up for anthracnose so
let's leave that aside let's leave that
aside you'll get anthracnose early if
you put on too much stress right yes and
we have seen that already you have seen
that already I have anthracnose samples
this week already so okay so early
season anthracnose is a fascinating
phenomenon right yeah it is because of
what we've learned about this let's I'm
going to stop here let's take go off uh
what do you think that's about too much
stress too dry what is going on this sir
yeah I think I think there's two things
going on one I think they had it going
into the winter I'm not a I'm not a
proponent of really really early season
new infections I think the soil
temperatures have to be a little higher
that and that low temperature threshold
for disease activity is not real well uh
uh defined but I think it's somewhere in
the 55-65 range you know so so I think
this the samples are coming with the
anthracnose over the winter but it's
really dry you know we we talked about
how we're starting to see the dry we're
above average temperature and it's
public golf courses that are getting
play all winter and you know you got 80
degree days you got 200 guys out there
hitting the balls and so they have to
mow there's getting traffic and there's
a lot of stress already in the system so
okay so that's what's a good qualifier
Carl in our case here that to really
call out moisture stress
on healthy plants
that didn't start the spring behind the
eight ball like Rick rich is talking
about here with with early season
anthracnose because of traffic stress
mechanical stress drought stress maybe
just cold weather and no growth stress
right I mean you're beating these things
up getting them ready right they're
getting traffic rich but they're not
growing so let's get it well it's 80
degrees one day and it's 55 the next you
know so so you know we're growing for a
couple days and we're not growing for a
week so so you know but guys are still
golfing right so so so okay you when it
dried out
wouldn't you have thought last year you
would have saw more summer patch well we
did and and that's an interesting thing
because we were wet in the period of
time in the spring when the pathogen was
starting to grow right and and moisture
you know I saw the slide from Eric
Nelson Eric always said that water is
the on and off switch and temperature is
the throttle right so if it's if we have
wet soils between the 62 the 62 to 80
degree range for soil temperatures
you're going to get more pathogen
activity and then you come to the summer
and you dry out and and you you're
getting that external stress on plants
that have a lot of that are carrying a
lot of pathogen then you're going to get
more disease and last year summer patch
was our number one prop it you know as a
diagnostic output
okay so back back on the summer patch
control train uh let's start with
ammonium sulfate do you like it as an
early season fertilizer yes I I just
just be careful not to push too much
growth right you know because you're
going to get top growth over root growth
or you know uh back to the the
agronomist side of it but but you know
the acidifying to the five and a half
range and ammonium sulfate seems like
one of the best choices for that
um is is a great tool it you know if
you're looking at three inch tall
Kentucky bluegrass it's almost all you
need to do you know
all right so okay so now we're coming
into the time with soil temperatures
based on the model that's in the Rutgers
diagnostic uh the the contempt the thing
from Kentucky that everybody's
contributed to that has efficacy and the
different products in it uh we're coming
to a two inch step mid-afternoon at
least 65 degrees C for five to six 65
degrees Fahrenheit for five to six days
so we're coming to that window Rich that
window is what Peak growth or what go
ahead that's that's when it's finally
warm enough to turn the fungus on and
get it to grow right so so you know the
the temperature ranges you know they do
them in a lab they grow grow at all
different temperatures see how fast it
grows yeah you know 65 to 82. you're
you're in that window where the throttle
is down yeah okay
so so here's what here's my question is
it because I got a lot of notes in the
last few days people like it looks like
it's warming up
is it summer past time I'm looking at
the soils I'm like I don't think the
soils are going yet for summer patch
yeah so is it okay to be early rather
than late with timing let's start with
timing on these things
how much protection do you get for how
long if you had to guess I I well first
of all you're not going to get control
of a pathogen unless it's growing and it
can it take up the material interact
with the material and that goes back to
Dr Latin you know in his textbooks and
stuff so timing matters like there's no
reason to put it out
you know before the fungus is starting
to grow which is why we have the
recommendations for the soil
temperatures because we know that's when
it's going to start to grow so
proceeding as close as you can to that
time period I think you're going to give
it the biggest dose you know and have
that effect okay so getting it down and
getting it in is going to take a bit of
time right we talk a lot about the
amount of water we did it with Mike
fedonza last week on the fairy ring
conversation I'm I'm starting to beat
this horse dead now uh that you got to
get enough water on it are you the the
fungus only interacts with the product
when it's starting to infect the root or
is the drench designed to really impact
the fungus in the soil and all the way
through that that is a great question I
I'm I'm gonna punt that one and I I
think it would have some effect you know
like a contact you know would have some
effect but I think that you know uh you
know and these materials are like fungal
growth regulators so having a steady
Source uh in the plant you know will
prevent it from invading the plant right
and so uh because we still see the
fungus even in in plants that are
healthy that are getting treated so it's
not like it's it's killing the fungus
and eradicating the pathogen just stops
it from growing for a little while you
know so Carl's point about the war of
attrition is well taken if it is
basically just you use a fungicide let's
say you get it at the right time you've
stunted it let's hope Roots can keep
growing or you've got enough because
once it's infected early on it's just
going to keep making its way into that
root system right deeper and deeper or
because at some point we used to tell
people you don't have to treat anymore
the darn thing is not going to keep
growing right but now it's like are you
saying guys have to drench every two to
three weeks the whole year now because
of the way this thing might infect and
grow I think I think well one the fungus
doesn't disappear right so when the
protection wanes then then it's that
battle how much root system do we have
can we keep the plants alive
and and so so because you know I've seen
guys on fungicide programs for 20 years
and the superintendent retires the new
guy doesn't know and it and it and it's
a storm of problems until they kind of
catch back up right and so so uh uh yeah
I I you have to have regular drenches to
keep that fungus you know whatever you
can do like soil PH or or manganese you
know uh uh uh additions to the fertility
program or fungicides to keep that
fungus from growing anymore than it has
to then you can you can start to win you
know that's the battle keep the roots
growing from an agronomic standpoint and
try to suppress the fungus as much as
you can and if you can get that balance
you get through the season
okay so listen since you brought up the
fungicide thing we're here now we got
about five more minutes let's talk a
little bit about a problem that seemed
to come up in a conversation with our
State Park Golf Course superintendents
there's like Frank we gotta use you know
you telling us you know rotate you're
telling us uh you know use different
things uh we're gonna have more summer
patch problems
um I use a lot of Combos and Rich you
look at this thing which people can't
see or aren't watching us on NewsChannel
10 here that is a lot of 11 and threes
here there's a lot of 11 Track codes and
eleven a lot of Threes And I bet a lot
of guys are not always using it is this
am I should I be worried about this this
seemed like something I wasn't paying
attention to until the superintendent
asked me now there are singular active
ingredients like a firm oh that's for
Fairy ring wait oh I didn't I got the
wrong one here's the fun this is the
thing off Wisconsin
yeah it's the same thing uh I put in a
summer patch and it gave me sevens and
elevens uh threes and elevens almost all
threes and elevens yeah on the mode of
action rating how do what do you tell
guys when they use this is this
something we need to be mindful of or
just get the darn thing controlled it's
not going to get resistant with Summer
pass we we've never had a a situation
where we could confirm that there was a
resistance problem okay right so so I I
but I will caution you if you're using a
lot of uh DMI materials that dollar spot
is an issue right so so so again I I
think that you can use the you use the
materials you know but I would
definitely you know a couple of dmis and
a couple of strobies and you're good we
also know that thiophaneate methyl is a
pretty darn good summer patch control so
that's something you could rotate in
even with the restrictions that we see
coming down the pike on on how much you
can use you know a shot of that
is a good dollar spot control too and
that might you know help you use a
little bit less DMI
okay there you go so no confirmed
resistance of Summer patch organisms to
any facade program them so that's
interesting to hear the dollar spot
thing is uh odd because you know you put
a DMI on and you've got to water it in
uh for summer patch but a dollar spot
what product you leave on the surface so
if you're using it for summer patch
water it in because that's likely to
help a little bit with dollar spot
resistance so you're saying we'll have
enough thiophanate methyl even with the
restrictions to get good control I think
I think so I mean you know how how many
times you're going to use it maybe once
maybe twice
the only other disease where we really
like it is gray leaf spot you know and
and so you know you save it for a gray
leaf spot app in the fall and maybe you
do one for summer patch in the spring
and you're probably still under the
under the threshold for use
okay last thing here is the early season
dollar spot we got a buzz about this you
brought it up just thank you for doing
that the dmis we use also create dollar
spot issues
um I remember this was tested a number
of times and it looked like things like
ipra Dion and vinclasolin might have had
some benefits those products are not
widely used nor available as much as
they used to be do you like this as a
early season program uh I know you're
not a fan of early season stuff I would
imagine this isn't something you
necessarily support that it works either
moving forward and lowering your dollar
spot risk as you get into the season
right right so so if you know if you're
going to use a DMI for summer patch and
you hit in the 65 soil temperatures you
know we've had that on our turf grass
Farm around mid-may mid May 15th you
know that's about the same time if if we
if I think back to all my times spent
with James hemphilling on the on the
farm
um he would say 15 March or May 15th May
20th that's about when Dollar spot
always starts for us right so you know
if you have so your first shot of banner
or you know broken is all for summer
patch is is right in line with your
dollar spot program
right you know just you know but with
dollar spot just there's more pressure
to mix it up right and so you're gonna
come back in a couple of weeks with with
uh you know uh uh you know one of the
sdhi materials or something right right
okay you know it'll work all right Carl
we weren't lying and we got bonus
content at the beginning of this thing
uh any burning questions otherwise we'll
get rich out of here I I think we nailed
it right on the head Frank I've got I've
got a whole list of notes I just made
people can't see this but I just make
notes I learn stuff going through this
so I got a whole page of notes that I've
got now from your conversation I was
writing down notes about irrigation and
Roots at the beginning too so even even
we learn stuff from this Frank it's it's
learning opportunity for us too and at
any time we're talking I I'm trying to
absorb something so it's all good hey
Richard well thanks everyone see you at
the Cornell Show Carl get us out of here
yeah rich rich wasn't going to be able
to Shell out the money they're going for
a lot of money yeah nobody I know has a
ticket nobody I know has a ticket so you
know if you want to pay five grand for a
dead show
I'm going to Los Angeles in the middle
of May and my tickets cost 150 bucks so
all right there you go economical
deadheads is how rich does it right
thanks everyone for joining the Cornell
Turf Show today we'll be back tomorrow
with a sports show uh but until then
everybody enjoy the weather take care
thanks Rich thanks Carl
thanks Rich see you this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at cornell.edu